thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
alexander grisha who just
finished his tournament on a very
respectable plus one
sasha first of all congratulations what
give us your first thoughts about
the tournament yes thank you yes i'm
very happy with the result
not happy about play my play but the
result is fine
in the end yeah it could go both ways
because for example yesterday
i was both losing and winning
so yeah but today i was suffering the
whole game so of course
draw is a very good result the take us
where did you feel like suffering
actually
us some insight because i don't know
like this i thought
um will be worse after just taking but i
guess computer
but why what
okay so completely misunderstanding by
me i thought that would be worse but
in fact it's slightly better yeah and
uh yeah okay but this uh this thing was
i thought to play d5 or let's say taken
g5
but then i didn't like that he takes the
e
file for example here he plays here and
then he plays rookie one and he has
initiatives this knight is powerful so i
didn't like it so i played
a8 and then i realized that he has
knight b6
because now i don't have this uh uh
swinging 65 yeah because yeah he can
take
unlike if i don't include rook 8
1 so now i have to take but e5
and knight c4 knight h4 is very
unpleasant
he has a 4 i should be able to defend
somehow but it's very unpleasant
but somehow he missed it and then
already
surprisingly at least for me it was uh
to hear that this is your first time in
bucharest what did you think about the
city and the organization of the
tournament yeah i
already said that very nice city
actually one of the nicest
i have been at
very you know old fashioned
like you really feel like you go back in
time some 20 30 years
very very nice and the
organization is fine as well sasha you
have so many fans around the world what
is next for you
in terms of tournaments i guess zagreb
if i make it to the zagreb it is you're
continuing in the grand chester
no that's my plan yeah after that any
other tournaments are we going forward
world cup of course perfect well we're
looking forward to see you in those
tournaments
sasha thank you back to you